sebastian liege deckt fünf tricks auf
einen schlag auf stress licht und klonen
sorgen für perfekten geschmack und
tolles aussehen bei fünf verschiedenen
lebensmitteln das quiz zum mitraten
beginnt jetzt
[Musik]
bei all diesen produkten wendet die
lebensmittelindustrie einen trick an
welcher trägt zur jeweiligen produkt
gehört habe ich hier auf die tafel
geschrieben und die müsstet ihr hier zu
dem jeweiligen produkt zu ordnen
also doch nicht so einfach wie gedacht
wer wird schön durch lampenlicht und wer
reift durch chemie welche pflanze hat
noch nie erde gesehen und wer ist nur
als clown besonders lecker unsere erste
clips frage wer oder was wächst durch
stricks die ananas die pilze vielleicht
die tomaten oder doch der lack
wächst durch stress ja das würde ich mal
hier zu dem lachs ok zuordnen
stress dann wird sich auch jetzt
eigentlich als erstes an sich denken
weil so eine gestresste tun damit sie
wirklich saftiger werden die
durchblutung wird
[Musik]
der pilz gestimmt
fischbeck sonst durch das richtig essenz
zucht champignons die im dauerstress
leben eigentlich wächst das geflecht aus
pilzfäden unsichtbar im boden nur im
herbst bildet es sichtbare fruchtkörper
die wir als pilze kennen damit die das
ganze jahr über sprießen wird das bild
ab und zu mit einer lehmschicht bedeckt
wie im herbst fehlen dem pilz dann luft
und nährstoffe und er treibt vor lauter
stress aus schön durch licht bleibt
dagegen lachs normalerweise nehmen die
silbrigen fische im herbst und winter
eine wenig appetitliche rotbraune farbe
an
um das zu verhindern nutzen züchter
einen einfachen trick
mit unterwasser lampen gaukeln sie den
tieren vor dass es immer noch sommer ist
dadurch bleiben sie schön silbrig und
attraktiv für die verbraucher
am düsseldorfer rheinufer geht sebastian
legis quiz in die nächste runde
diesmal geht es um die frage wer nur als
clown besonders lecker schmeckt die
ananas das basilikum oder vielleicht
tomaten
[Musik]
als clown besonders lecker lecker als
clown als clown besonders lecker
gibt es irgendwelche tipps
also kloten zum beispiel bei tomaten
sagen jawohl oder pilze weil sie teuer
sind dann kann es natürlich viel viel
geld machen
oder vielleicht beim fisch als chrome
besonders lecker die richtige antwort
lautet die ananas ist nur als clown
genießbar
denn von natur aus hätte sie tausende
kleiner harter kern so würde sie niemand
essen was wir kaufen sind sterile ananas
worten die durch schützlinge vermehrt
also geklont wurden
das hat nichts mit gentechnik zu tun
sondern wird von züchtern seit
ewigkeiten praktiziert
zwei fragen bleiben noch wer reift wohl
durch chemie und welche pflanze hat noch
nie erde gesehen
die düsseldorfer liegen mit ihren tipps
mal wieder voll daneben
ist alles falsch alles alles über gott
so schlimm ist nichts richtig also reif
durch chemie wird so manche tomate
besser termingerecht reifen tomaten
werden ja nicht alle gleichzeitig roth
die züchter greifen auf einen trick der
natur zurück apple etwa strömen ein gas
namens e10 aus und greifen deshalb zur
gleichen zeit und künstlich
hergestelltes ethen wirkt auch bei
tomaten und damit ist auch klar wer in
seinem leben noch niemals erde gesehen
hat es ist
[Musik]
das publikum
in den niederlanden nach endhoven
schauen wir uns an wie das funktioniert
in einer sogenannten in dörfer unter
kunstlicht werden salat basilikum und
andere kräuter auch für deutsche
supermärkte produziert
[Musik]
anstatt in erde wachsen die wurzeln hier
tatsächlich in einer nährlösung deren
zusammensetzung computer genau gesteuert
wird
[Musik]
das wasser das wir hier verbrauchen geht
komplett ins wachstum der pflanze es
läuft nichts davon oder verdunstet es
wird immer wieder verwendet wenn man
vergleicht wie viel wasser wir zum anbau
von einem kilo salat verbrauchen dann
kommen wir hier drin auf anderthalb
liter und draußen auf dem feld wäre es
etwa zehn mal so viel
das gleiche bei basilikum
hochgerechnet aufs kilo sind gerade mal
1,5 liter wasser nötig im freiland
verbraucht man die zehnfache menge
[Musik]
die energiebilanz ist da schon
komplizierter klar die anlage verbraucht
strom und wärme aber langfristig geht es
darum so etwas auch mitten in
großstädten zu bauen
im büro oder wohnhäusern kurze wege zum
kunden das spart energie bei transport
und lagerung und pestizide
denn in dieser sterilen welt gibt es
keine schädlinge
ob die rechnung wirklich aufgeht weiß
noch niemand was ich schon heute gut
verkauft sind schnell wachsende salate
und kräuter wie basilikum und als
nächstes erdbeeren im winter
das hängt von vielen faktoren ab
erdbeeren seien sehr gut mit dem
richtigen beleuchtungs programm sind sie
sogar um 20% süßer die schmecken besser
als von draußen aber aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht ist der anbau
noch nicht lukrativ da wären unsere
erdbeeren zu teuer bis obst und gemüse
aus indorf armen billiger wird als das
vom feld dürfte es noch etwas dauern
doch dem einfallsreichtum der züchter
wird es auch künftig gelingen die natur
noch weiter auszutricksen durchaus auch
zum nutzen der verbraucher
clevere verbesserungen oder
unnatürlicher turbo anbau wie steht ihr
zu den tricks sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
lebensmittel wissen wollt schaut die
nächsten zwei clips und abonniert die
zdf besser ist